ready to get going after a rain delay
which is just about at two hours
and the tigers will take their swings
against keegan aiken
and down goes grossman
aitkin picks up a k to start his night
and here comes miguel cabrera
sitting on 498.
a fly ball from cabrera will stay in the
yard
to right center field and it is nearly
not caught
and it is a one two three first inning
take a look at casey mize's numbers six
and six out of the years pitch very well
you're seeing a lot of growth the payoff
to aureus and he blows it by him
two away
on the ground to third
a good start for casey mize and the
tigers 16 pitches and he retires the
royals one two three
and so far so good he struck out two of
the first four
[Applause]
and this time haas goes down swinging on
a second consecutive changeup and now a
call for willy castro
castro with a fly ball to right field
santander looking up that ball is off
the wall santander plays it
and misses the cutoff man
goodroom scores all the way from first
willy castro has himself an rbi double
the tigers on the board one nothing for
akiel badu
the other way that's a fair ball into
the left field corner willie castro will
score takes a weird hop away from austin
hayes but dude digging for three
and he is in there with a pop-up slide
that is his sixth triple of the year to
lead the american league and the tigers
are in front two-nothing
six-game hit streak for santander
golf to right field will this one stay
fair it is gonna stay fair and is good
anthony santander just peppering this
field with lasers
one of them was due to stay in between
the lines and that's the one
a long home run
utah street bound to right field to put
the orioles on the board
there goes the runner to throw from haas
in time to get him right there
perfect throw from eric haas
the tag made and what a job to get out
of the inning
jonathan scope pounds win to the right
center field gap that's all the way to
the wall
grossman will hustle he will score
on the jonathan scope rbi double niko
goodrum from the old one
past the shortstop
mateo and into left field for an rbi
single
for nico goodrum and the tigers add to
their lead it's now 4-1 detroit keeps
the line moving for willy castro
1-2 to castro line to right center field
that's up the gap cabrera will score
goodram is being waved home and he will
score uris dropped it and willy castro
motors all the way to third
now the 2-1
grounded to third candelario will take
it himself
casey mize and the tigers get out of it
in the third and we are through three in
baltimore
a hitch in the delivery
scope still hit it pretty well but
mullins was well positioned
eight batters faced in the big leagues
eight batters retired
for marcos duplant anthony santander who
hit his fifth career utah street home
run in the second
that ball is belted left center field
and he did it again
a two-home run night for anthony
santander
one on to utah street
one
into the seats in left center
and this is as locked in
as we have seen anthony santonder maybe
since last season
dj stewart has just broken out of his
home run drought in a major way
oh a high towering drive to the flag
cord the orioles second home run of the
inning
cedric mullins slams one into center
field
and there is a 17-game head streak and a
head streak extended with a double
cedric never stopped going
and he picks up double number 29.
a ground ball should score the run
unless it's back to the pitcher and he
throws it away
oh my goodness
will go to second mullins will score
it was not a great throw
from mize to scope and the orioles are
within six to four
crown ball to second
one mateo
two
and badou waves at strike three there
you go
fly ball right field deep grossman's got
it on the warning track
and baltimore goes one two three in the
sixth against kyle funkhouser
on the ground to second this could be
two marias mateo mancini ring him up
second straight inning the orioles turn
of four six three double play
the one one
fly ball left field badou gives chase
he's got it
and the orioles
go one two three against jose cisnero in
the seventh candelario looking to get on
track he has struck out looking twice
2-2
candelario skies one to deep right field
that ball is gone
jamer candelario with a two-run shot
a little a couple of insurance runs for
the tigers and it's 8-4
santander to deep left center field
hill tracking it but oh and they collide
hill held on to the ball
somehow some way held on to that ball
both men remain down
but dew and hill just collided at full
speed on a drive to the deep left center
field gap
oh
both are down oh my god
this is ripped to left center
[Applause]
grinder is going to try and score
throw all the way to the plate he scores
standing up and it's an rbi single for
robbie grossman
[Applause]
ground ball to third that should end it
job well done by gregory soto as usual
and the tigers
knock off the orioles 9-4 to start this
series at camden yards